ازمه اجناء الرعايه الاجانب من السودان
تجد طريقها للحل فالوفود الاجنبيه بات
بامكانها اخيرا الهرب من جحيم المعارك
المتواصله الجيش السوداني اعلن موافقه
قائده الاعلى عبد الفتاح البرهان على
تسهيل عمليه مغادره الرعايه الاجانب ليضع
حدا لاسبوع من الترقب والقلق المهمه لم
تنتهي بموافقه البرهان فطريق المغادره
طويل وشاق حيث يمر عبر مرحلتين فتوقف مطار
الخرطوم عن العمل بعد الاضرار التي تعرض
لها خلال الاشتباكات جعل من مطار
بورتسودان الحل الوحيد المتاحه في الوقت
الراهن لذا فعمليه الاجلاء تبدا بالوصول
برا الى بورتسودان التي تقع شمال شرقي
البلاد على الساحل الغربي للبحر الاحمر
وتبعد عن العاصمه الخرطوم بنحو 675
كيلومترا ويتطلب الوصول اليها برا ازيد من
12 ساعه وبمجرد الوصول الى بورسودان يمكن
استخدام مطارها الجوي
من اجل المغادره العديد من الدول باشرت
عمليات اجلاء مواطنيها من بينها السعوديه
الاردن الولايات المتحده بريطانيا الصين
فرنسا والنرويج ووفقا لجيش السوداني فان
بعض عمليات الاجلاء تتم عبر رحلات عسكريه
بطائرات هليكوبتر من الخرطوم الى
بورتسودان قبل ان تستكمل عبر رحلات جويه
اخرى
وبينما وجدت وفود من الرعايه مخرجا لها من
هذا المازق لا تزال اخرى تنتظر دورها
للمغادره وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات